this is serious Steven oh I got
strawberries now now I want strawberries
the secret to a good comedy by the way
is always have them in your eyes that's
what made wicker man so great and you
know what actually made that really
funny was you know he's saying the
Messiah he doesn't take a pause and go
ah he just goes right into my eyes it
was like a perfect lead-in like Family
Guy with the record ah oh so okay so
this episode they do this very funky
time thing where it's like it wakes up
with like police sirens going any wakes
up a sad since our carnival and it's
like tea cups in these giant teacups
everywhere on top of buildings and in
the water it's like two weeks later I'm
like what do mean two weeks earlier is
that usually how this works I like
really did that um and they're taking
about a mission so he needs to be really
serious on this mission and I get
another one these gems so they let the
fact that they're like this is a gem
battlefield and there's the same swords
everywhere that you saw in pearls
headquarters of room or whatever so I
feel like it's more this mythos building
like so no I like I guess they live in
these Lord of the Rings battles yeah
hieroglyphics um yeah I mean one was
definitely his mother stopping like such
a bad person
front sorry I forgot to mention Assam I
didn't notice that there's apparently a
portrait of his mother above the door
yeah I'm assuming it's his mother
because it's got a star and like a you
know yeah they're kinda the pink and you
never like to see her face like it's
always hidden you tortured we saw her
face before at least I didn't see it at
least a bad episode no no and that
doesn't serve a like a beam covering up
I don't know if they're like keeping it
a secret if we actually saw it before an
untrue so we get to this like this Lord
of the Rings mythos going on here these
ancient gem are bees fighting like I
said that temples are on or something I
yeah I really want to know the the story
behind the one holding
and out everything I mean one of the
story behind that thing uh but okay so
they go to this this other temple that
really seems to like triangles and they
tell Steven to try and be serious a
garner garnet uh takes him with and he's
trying not to relive the teacup incident
because apparently he got too afraid and
he jumped out of the teacup there was
some implicitness and he can never go
back to fun land
yes and caused the guy to throw the tea
cups everywhere that that guy's my
favorite thing just the minute he showed
up one
hahaha and then again come on you are
bad form on the right here and he still
kept the big smile of anything he got
bigger what he said well that was that
was like Greg stiffy again I want me
funny
I like seem like I get like a Legend of
Zelda vibe of like this kind of quest
aspect of there's all these dungeons and
palaces that need to be closed
somehow or deactivated well and how they
keep running back to the same place
that's very well I love the mechanics
behind this one was fun how they all had
this different thing going in this one
yeah they keep spinning you around in
room in room so he's out up in the same
location I like when they fell through
the ground and they're on those
triangles spinning around well I like
what a kid Stephen is my favorite moment
is when she's garnets holding up these
these spikes falling from the wallet up
and like he's like oh yeah qawalli
yeah that's so good and I'm just like
that's such a dumb kid big zoo like just
completely oblivious to everything else
around him I've seen kids do that where
it's like you know you could have a fire
going on in the background then they're
like sitting there on their Gameboy like
oh man this is like or like my dolly
it's like no no that's it there's a
fucking fire there don't go after that
yeah you always went after your dolly
always cuz it was important Rainbow
Brite was pushes hard um moving on this
is ah no let's talk more about rainbow
um I'll be kind of are with this yeah I
just have s it doesn't right fine yeah
um yeah I think what else it definitely
is a show in touch with its feminine
side
um well most of May characters are win
and I think that would probably play a
part that helps Oh Vic it's written by
women then also yes uh the lectures
various writers I let it Darby all just
lie she don't like Sookie away I should
say created by uh yeah great be
impressive they're all written by there
definitely are some shows are like
mostly dumped by one person like you
know ring for like that Louise like that
what else have is it oh I look I love
that final room where it's not only like
flames on the floor but it's flames on
the floor and like strivings it and then
the lava falls on the only like parapet
standing leg left I'm like holy fuck
doesn't it also explode yeah but that
all sorts and somehow she got through it
Steven
this is going to get a little intense
like yeah and then she gets through a
wall Steven takes it they're just also
such a kid thing to do why this rumor I
just remember you passed out I just
remember well I guess kids you can sleep
through anything we added stirred he
could have also just passed out um but
that's also a kid thing to do
depending on what you're doing oh yeah
no I suppose it was a lot of fun yeah
I'm trying to do uh try think there's
much else to it I mean say like a
general quest thing and I love uh how do
I put he's sort of becoming like one of
those I don't know he remembered
earthworm jim to like that little slime
pack where you just it's like this
living thing yet he smashed against
these waltzes swing around that's kind
of I feel like with Steven like you just
take them and throw them and you can
smash against row but it's fine
no I here we go I like doesn't care
oh can you put me down it only works if
I'm standing so sis Michelle yes of
course
um again a very kid thing to do so uh
yeah yeah I don't know what else to say
I like yeah it was good I feel bad cuz
it's not like you know I was only okay
like it was good it's good episode but
I'm not finding too much else to say
about it um you know it was cool like
and we're also at the end of our run to
like yeah we did we had to watch the
next movie for the NC take all the
notes for that we did two real thoughts
which was yes it Don Bluth and Disney
Afternoon so they were very long and
then three episodes I think my brains
finally just like it doesn't get last
time you'll see you saw these clothes
400 yeah I get my brains like um but ya
know I like I like em the video game
element that it'll have the right show
video game element that's it seems to be
cabin air love it okay then if we're
talk about that I also love the sound
design of the show yeah a little music
good yeah almost sound um yeah and the
the background still look I'm paying
more and more attention to the
background because I don't see these
kind of backgrounds that much it's not
something I would usually be like you
know oh I'm you know really excited to
see that but it's I don't know and since
it is so rad I see it and there's
clearly a lot of technique there isn't
this button leads to more triangles oh
no it was a good episode just a fun
adventure episode and uh yeah camping it
too much else just um okay times good
times
hey I hope you have fun seeing us in
these clothes for probably a week Oh cuz
these are all gonna go up in a row um
and uh yeah that's about it we will see
you have barely been here for five days
straight
I smell great I smell like roses and was
eaten by a pig we already did that Jacob
it's not funny anymore it is funny
because I brought best just stop now
you're doing the pointing thing like
you're doing an 80's freeze-frame like
see it doesn't work
I